[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
مع تجدد المعارك في السودان طرفان نزاع
يتبادلان الاتهامات بخلق الهدنه والازمه
الانسانيه تتفاقم
وهجوم سيبراني صيني يقلق واشنطن
ومايكروسوفت تحذر من هجمات اوسع في انحاء
العالم
اهلا بكم يتواصل في السودان خرق الهدنه
ويتواصل معها تبادل المسؤوليه عن خلقها
بين طرفي النزاع وضمن تبادل البيانات اتهم
الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بمواصله
انتهاك الهدنه بينما تتهم الاخيره الجيش
بمهاجمه قواتها وعلى الارض بددت
الاشتباكات المتقطعه امال السودانيين بوقف
النار فيما ينذر استمرار المعارك بتفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه والصحيه في انحاء البلاد
ووسط تجدد خلق الهدنه اكثر من مره منذ
دخولها حيزه تنفيذ ليلى الاثنين تسعى لجنه
المتابعه والتنسيق لاعاده الهدوء ووقف
اطلاق النار هذه اللجنه مشاهدينا تعنى
بمراقبه الهدنه وفق ما نص عليه اتفاق جده
وتضم تلك اللجنه قيادات من طرفي النزاع
بالاضافه الى مسؤولنا سعوديين وامريكيين
اما بالنسبه لاليه عملها فلا تفاصيل كثيره
عنها الا ان بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين
كانوا المحوا سابقا الى احتمال استعانتها
بالاقمار الصناعيه والى جانب المراقبه عن
بعد لا شك ان تلك الاليه ستدرس ايضا او
تدرس الاتهامات المتبادله التي يتقادفها
الجانبان عللا وعبر بيانات رسميه للتحقق
من هذه الانتهاكات حول ذلك وللمزيد ينضم
الينا من ام درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن اهلا
بك معنا مقداد اذا خروقات مستمره ولا
معلومات مؤكده حول من يبدا هذه الخروقات
ومن يستمر بها ولكن انقل لنا الصوره لديك
حول ذلك هل ما زالت قائمه الخروقات هل ما
زلتم تسمعون
داويين انفجارات طلق نار طيران جوي ان كان
في ام درمان او المناطق التي فيها
اشتباكات ايضا مثل بحري والخرطوم كذلك
نعم فاطمه بالامس كانت الاشتباكات
القصف الجوي بالاضافه الى المدافع الثقيله
كانت هي سيده المشهد وكانت الاصوات عاليه
جدا ولكن في الساعات الاخيره من الليل بدت
هنالك طلقات متقطعه واشتباكات ومطاردات
داخل احياء مدينه شمال ام درمان تحديدا
مما يعني ان الاشتباكات قد يعني نقصت
حدتها في في ساعات المتاخره من الليل وحتى
الساعات الاولى من الصباح هنالك هدوء كبير
في مدينه درمان خصوصا في شمالها وجنوبها
لكن شوهد الطائرات الاستطلاع في هذا
الصباح تحلق في سماء ديرمان وسمعت ايضا
اشتباكات متقطعه في وسط الخرطوم وبالتالي
فان التجدد هذه الاشتباكات
وكذلك ينتظر من الاليه المراقبه ان تفعل
الهدنه بطريقه وانت يلتزم الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بالهدنه حتى تصل
المساعدات الانسانيه لمدينه ام درمان
والخرطوم وبحري والتي يعني نشهد فيها
انقطاع كبير في اغلب امدادات الغذاء
والدواء وكذلك الخدمات الاساسيه من مياه
وكهرباء مدينه بحري على وجه الخصوص تشهد
انقطاعا للمياه منذ بدء هذه المواجهات
وكذلك احياء كثيره جدا من مدينه ام درمان
تنقطع فيها خدمات المياه والكهرباء ويعاني
المواطنين بصوره واضحه وبالغه جدا خاصه في
المناطق التي تقع في محيط النار او محيط
المناطق الاستراتيجيه كسلاح المهندسين
والسلاح الطبي والهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون وكذلك الجنوبي مدينه ام درمان
حيث معسكرات الدعم السريع
بما يخص القوافل الانسانيه والجانب
الانساني بحسب من تحدثنا اليهم من اللجنه
العليا لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه تحدث عن
انه هنالك
مساعدات غذائيه وصلت الى شمال مدينه ام
درمان حيث قاعده وادي العسكريه لكن لا
وجود لسلاسل او شبكات امداد لان بحسب هذه
اللجنه تقول ان الطرفين لم يلتزم التزاما
واضحا وهناك التوترات امنيه واضحه تمنع
دخول هذه المساعدات الغذائيه فيما يخص
المساعدات الطبيه كانت اللجنه الهلال
الاحمر ووزاره الصحه ايضا كانت قد تسلمت
هذه
المعينات الطبيه ولكن ايضا تواجهها صعوبات
بالغه في ايصالها الى المستشفيات المطلوبه
هنالك حديث عن ان مستشفى النوم في مدينه
ام درمان وكذلك مستشفى بشاير في العاصمه
الخرطوم جنوبي الخرطوم والمستشفى التركي
قد تسلمت بعض من هذه الادويه
والمعينات الطبيه والمستلزمات الطبيه هذا
هو المشهد كاملا بما يخص المساعدات الطبيه
والغذائيه نشاهد يعني مشاكل انسانيه بالغه
وصعوبه وتعقيد كبير في السلاسل تامين
الكوادر التي تعمل
هذه المعضله والمشاكل الانسانيه التي
يواجهونها المواطنون السودانيون اثر هذه
المعارك والاشتباكات مع ضيفنا التالي شكرا
جزيلا لك من ام درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن
نبقى في السودان حرب دارت رحاها منذ اكثر
من شهر ونصف المنهك الوحيد منها المدنيون
السعون الى ملجا لرصاص فيخترقه فهذا البلد
الذي يعد احد اكبر تجمعات اللاجئين في
افريقيا
باتلاجئا السودان ومع كل قصف يعكر سماءه
تتضاعف اعداد لاجئيه وحتى نزحيه منظمه
الهجره الدوليه تحدثت عن مليون نازح بين
الولايات ابواب الاهالي فتحت على مصرعيها
لتغيث الفارين ولكن الى اين السبيل في
الفرار من موت الى موت ابعد ضاقت بهم
السبل فحتى الاخر منهم مجردون اصطف وا في
طوابير تمتد على حدوده فكانت مصر تشاد
واثيوبيا ملاذا ولو كان بعيدا وشاقا اوضاع
انسانيه لم تصفها الامم المتحده سوى
بالمفجعه كلمه قد تغص بحجم معاناه ويلات
الحرب لكنها بالتاكيد لا تواسي المفجوعين
بفقدان احد افراد اسرتهم
[موسيقى]
هو منذ بدايه تلك الاشتباكات العنيفه
ارتفع عدد الوفيات بين المدنيين الى
وثلاثه الاف وستمائه واربعين اصابه وفق ما
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان مضيفه ان هناك
عددا كبيرا من الاصابات والوفيات لم يتم
التبليغ عنها وذلك بسبب عدم قدره وصول
المختصين الى المستشفيات او حتى نقل الجثث
الى المشارح
وبالحديث عن الوضع الانساني للنازحين
واللاجئين السودانيين في تشاد وحدها ازمه
كارثيه هكذا وصفتها صحيفه ديكوردينا
البريطانيه التي رصدت ان اكثر من 80 الف
لاجئ سوداني غالبيتهم من النساء والاطفال
ممن هربوا الى تشاد يواجهون ازمه خطيره في
ظل انعدام توفير الامدادات الغذائيه
والمساعدات خصوصا مع بدايه موسم الامطار
المنتظره وهو ما حذرت منه ايضا منظمه
الصليب الاحمر
اللجوء ونقص الغذاء
اكثر ما يعاني منه اللاجئون السودانيون في
التشاد نتحدث اكثر من العاصمه الكينيه
نيروبي مع المتحدث الرسمي باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في افريقيا
اليونا سنينكو اهلا بك معنا اليونا اذا
وضع انساني صعب في تشاد بسبب الازمه
والاشتباكات والحرب في السودان
اثر هذه الازمه كيف تقيمين الوضع الانساني
ونحن نتحدث عن المساعدات الغذائيه
المساعدات الطبيه الاعداد التي لا يمكن
حصرها بسبب انعدام امكانيه الوصول الى
الجثث او حتى نقلها كيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الوضع الصعب
[تصفيق]
كما قلتم تماما الوضع كارثي عندما نتحدث
عن
الدوله في جنوب السودان علينا ان لا ننسى
ان هناك الكثير من المدنيين ما زالوا في
المناطق التي تتاثر باقتتال في الخرطوم
ودارفور وهناك من
ينزحون
اما داخل البلاد او يلجاون عبر الحدود
فالوضع عندما يصبح اكثر صعوبه في المنطقه
وفي الدول الجوار
لانه على مدى سنوات طويله كانت
السودان تستقبل اللاجئين كانت تستقبل وان
كانت تستضيفه مليون لاجئ والان هؤلاء
يضطرون الفرار من جديد ويعبرون الحدود
للدول دول الجوار حيث الوضع الانساني صعب
الى حد كبير على مدى السنوات الاخيره
فلديهم تحدياتهم ومن الصعب جدا استيعاب
هذا العدد الكبير من الافراد في هذا الوقت
القصير طيب ما الخيارات امامكم
الناس الذين خرجوا من الحرب في تشاد ام هل
تركزون في مساعدتكم على الداخل السوداني
ما المتاح امامكم
كلجنه دوليه للصليب الاحمر تركيزنا
الاساسي هو مساعده من هم ما زالوا في
السودان لان هذا هو تخويلنا مساعده
المتاثرين
لساعات المسلحه فالاولويه هي ايصال
المعدات الطبيه للمستشفيات
فالنظام الصحي على شفير الانهيار
ومرافق كثيره لا تعمل ونحن نعمل ايضا عن
كتب من ما شركائنا من حركتي اساليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر ونعمل مع الدول الجوار مع
جمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
واتحاد الصليب الاحمر لمساعدتهم في تقديم
جهودهم
للمتاثرين
الهلال الاحمر المصري
واساليب الاحمر في جنوب السودان ودول اخرى
كانت تحشد مواردها لمساعده من يعبرون
الحدود ما الصعوبات التي تواجهونها لايصال
هذه المساعدات خصوصا في ظل الخروقات التي
نشهدها للهدنه التي يعني لم تكمل يومين
وما زال هناك خروقات بالتالي ما هي تلك
الصعوبات التي تواجهونها هل انتم قادرون
على ايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين
تشالنج هازبيل هو بالطبع
الاقتتال المتواصل غير المتوقف الذي
شهدناه على مدى اكثر من خمسه اسابيع
والمفاوضات والاتفاقات التي تم التوصل
اليها بالطبع
هي خطوه ايجابيه كبيره
وتاكيد اثرت على الوضع
بالاقتتال الذي هدا بعض الشيء لكن للاسف
ما زال هناك كثير من التحديات متبقيه فنحن
ايضا ننظر الى
الاجرام والخروج عن القانون
بسبب
عمليات النهب والوضع للاسف ما زال
متاججا
علينا مع ذلك ان نواصل عملنا وبذل كل
الجهود الممكنه لايصال المساعدات لمن
يحتاجونها فما من وقت
للهدر او الانتظار فالوضع الامني لن يصبح
مثاليا وبالتالي
قمنا بايصال
معدات جراحيه الى بورتودان وتم ايصالها
لوزاره الصحه
ووزاره الصحه بدورها قامت بايصال هذه
المعدات
الجراحيه للمستشفيات في خرطوم ونامل حقا
ان يبقى الوضع
مستقر وهادئ بما يكفي كي يواصلوا ايصال
هذه المعدات ماذا عن وضع اللاجئين خارج
السودان يعني نتحدث عن تشاد مصر اثيوبيا
جنوب السودان يعني دول عده احتوت اللاجئين
والذين تمكنوا من الفرور من النهب والسرقه
والضرب والاغتصاب كيف هي احوالهم هل
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه كافيه
لنجدتهم
[تصفيق]
كما ذكرت للتو فان اخذنا اي
في العالم
واستقبالها لهذا العدد
الكبير من
اللاجئين بوقت قصير فهذا تحدي كبير فهو
يضغط على الرعايه صحيه والمياه وكل
الموارد في الدوله حتى لو كانت دوله غنيه
ونحن نتحدث عن مناطق لديها
تحدياتها الامنيه على مدى سنوات طويله
وبالتالي غالبا المناطق التي يكون فيها
هناك من يناسب
المساعدات
الموارد المحليه ليست كبيره بما يكفي
وبالتالي الان عدد كبير ومهول من اللاجئين
يشكلوا الضغط على المجتمعات المحليه في
الدول التي تستقبلهم كي تتمكن من
استيعابهم وتقديم الخدمات اللازمه نعم
هناك منظمات بما فيها شركائنا الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر اللذين يعملان
لتلبيه الاحتياجات في هذا الوضع لكن في ظل
حجم الاحتياجات الكبيره من الصعب حشدها
وتوفير الرد الكافي في هذا الوقت القصير
شكرا جزيلا لك من العاصمه الكينيه نيروبي
المتحدثه الرسميه باسم اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في افريقيا اليوم سيلينكو
مستمرون معكم ونتابع
اكثر من سته ملايين طفلا يمنيا على بعد
خطوه واحده من المجاعه
احييكم من جديد اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي احباط هجوم اوكراني على منشات
نوويه روسيه في مقاطعتين عشيه اعيد النصر
وذكر بيان لجهاز الامن الروسي انه تم
اعتقاله ثلاثه اوكرانيين وروسيين اثنين
منهم شاركا في التخطيط للهجوم وفي تفاصيل
خطه الهجوم التي كشفت عنها او كشف عنها
الامن الروسي كان الهجوم يستهدف 30 خطا
لنقل الطاقه الى المحطتين النوويتين وبحسب
الامن الروسي اعترف الروسي المتورطون في
التخطيط للهجوم بتعاونهم مع الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه وانهم خضعوا الى تدريبات في
منطقتي كييف ونيك لايف في سبتمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
من موسكو معنا مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمى
اهلا بك معنا كاتيا اذا ما التفاصيل
المتوفره لديك حول هذا الهجوم الاوكراني
لمحطتين نوويتين او لاماكن نقل النفط الى
محطتين النوويتين تفضلي كاتيا
مرحبا بك فاطمه بالفعل تم اعلن جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي انه تم اعتقال مواطنين
اوكرانيين بالاضافه الى انه تم اعلان
البحث عن مواطن اخر يحمل الجنسيه
الاوكرانيه والروسيه هؤلاء تم
تدريبهم كما تحدث جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
وبعد اجراء تحقيقات اوليه معهم انهم تلقوا
تدريب في اوكرانيا في كييف ومقاطعه
الاوكرانيه ايضا كانوا يخططون لنقل
المتفجرات من الاراضي البولنديه عبر
ليطوانه مرورا بالاراضي البيلاروسيا
وبالتالي الى روسيا الى مقاطعه فير
المنطقه طبعا التي التي قاموا فيها بتفجير
عمود كهربائي وكانوا بالاساس هم يستهدفون
محطتين نوويتين
لتوليد الكهرباء وكان قد قاموا بترغيم
اربعه عوامل باضافه الى ذلك الى كانت هنا
لديهم نوايا
لتلغيم نحو 30 برج كهربائي وبهدف طبعا
هدفهم كان تفجير هذه
المناطق من اجل قطع الكهرباء وطبعا
استهداف البنيه التحتيه الروسيه هذاك كله
كان مخطط له قبيله طبعا اعياد عيد النصر
وبالتالي كما تعلمين قبيله عيد النصر كان
هناك ايضا محاوله لاستهداف الكريم
وبالتالي كما تحدثوا لك فاطمه هذه العمليه
تم احباطها من جهاز من قبل جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي التي طبعا اعلنت بدورها
ايضا
او كان يتعلق على هذا الموضوع الذي قال
انه بالتاكيد انه لا يملك ادنى شك بان
النظام كيف هو الذي يقف وراء هذه العمليه
ولذلك روسيا تستمر بعمليه العسكريه هناك
طبعا فاطمه ليست هذه المحاوله الاولى
تخريبيه التي تقوم روسيا باحباطها والتي
نشهد نشاطا كبيرا لعمل جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي في الاونه الاخيره على الاراضي
الروسيه كان هناك ايضا يوم امس القاء
القبض على مواطن روسي في منطقه رستوف عدد
دون وهي منطقه حدوديه ايضا مع اوكرانيا
كان يقوم بنقل معلومات يعمل هو لدى مؤسسه
عسكريه روسيه وكان يقوم بارسال المعلومات
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه حول اماكن تواجد
القوات الروسيه بالاضافه الى نظام الدفاع
الجوي الروسي كما تحدث ايضا جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي يوم امس فاطمه شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو مراسله العربيه على هذه المعلومات
على الجانب الاخر مشاهدينا الجانب
الاوكراني طبعا اكد الجيش على ان دفاعاته
الجويه صدت بالكامل هجوما جديدا ضخما جنته
القوات الروسيه على كييف بواسطه الطائرات
مسيره وهو الهجوم الثاني عشر من نوعه الذي
يستهدف العاصمه الاوكرانيه واوضح رئيس
الاداره المدنيه والعسكريه الاوكرانيه
سيرجي بوبكو ان القوات الروسيه هاجمت
مجددا كييف من الجو وان الانذار الجوي في
المدينه استمر لاكثر من ثلاث ساعات مشددا
ان هذا الهجوم الضخم نفدته طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شاهد وقد اتهم
الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي تهمه روسيا بشن
حمله ترهيب جديده ضد بلاده عبر شم هجمات
بس 36 طائره مسيره خلال الليل واشار الى
ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه نجحت في
اسقاط جميعها بنسبه 100% اما قائد مجموعات
فاجنر شبه العسكريه اعلن عن البدء
الاوكرانيه ياتي الانسحاب بعد ان اعلن في
وقت سابق ان رئيس مجموعه الذي تقود قواته
الهجوم على بخموت انه سيسلم مدينه في شرق
اوكرانيا الى القوات الروسيه النظاميه
ليحل محلهم كوريا الجنوبيه مشاهدينا
ارسلتني مئات الالاف من القذائف المدفعيه
الى اوكرانيا عبر الولايات المتحده بعد
اعتراض سول في بادئ الامر على تسليح كييف
وذلك بحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
الامريكيه الى ان سول توصلت الى ترتيب سري
مع واشنطن بعد ان طلبت الاخيره من حليفتها
الاسيويه العام الماضي ذلك الدعم في
المقابل وقعت روسيا وبيلاروسيا وثيقه
تعاون دفاعي تتضمن السماح بنشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في اراضي بيلاروسيا وذلك
خلال زياره وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويجو الى مينسك وذكر وزير الدفاع
بيلاروسيا ان الاتفاق يتضمن نشر صواريخ
اسكندر ام ومنظومه دفاع جوي من طراز اس
400 في اراضينا فضلا عن تجهيز طائرات صخور
25 لتكون قادره على حمل معدات نوويه مشيرا
الى تدريب طيارينا بيلاروس عليها
مجاعه تهدد اطفال اليمن منظمه الامم
المتحده للطفوله اليونيسف حذرت من ان اكثر
من 6 ملايين طفل في اليمن على بعد خطوه
واحده من المجاعه ما لم يتم اتخاذ اجراءات
عاجله طبعا تضمن توفير التمويل الكافي
لتقديم المساعدات لهم وكانت المنظمه
الدوليه قد اعلنت مطلع العام الجاري عن
احتياجها العاجل الى
484 مليون دولار لمواصله استجابتها
الانسانيه في اليمن خلال عام 20 23
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا تستمر ونتابع
في بريطانيا هل منح انخفاض التضخم بارقه
امل للمواطنين بعد ارتفاع الارتفاع
القياسي في الاسعار نعرف بعد قليل
اعتقاله واصابه عشرات الفلسطينيين بعمليات
اقتحام اسرائيليه متزامنه في اريحا ونابلس
هجوم سيبراني صيني يقلق واشنطن
ومايكروسوفت تحذر من هجمات اوسع في انحاء
العالم
احييكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن اصابه 18 فلسطينيين برصاص
الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب
مدينه اريحا وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي اقتحم
اريحا والمخيم واغلق بعض الطرق واعتقل
عددا من السكان وافرج عن معظمهم قبل ان
تنسحب القوات الاسرائيليه من المخيم في
مندلعت مواجهات خلال التوغل الاسرائيلي
وبالتزامن نفذ الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليه
توغل اخرى في نابلس واعتقال عدد من
الفلسطينيين فيما اصيب اخرون حول ذلك ينضم
الينا من مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا مراسل
العربيه خالد القاسم خالد انقل لنا الصوره
لديك وما المعلومات المتوفره حول هذا
الاقتحام والاعتقالات
نعم فاطمه انتهت العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في مخيم عقبه جبر قربه اريحا
عند الخامسه فجرا بعد ان استمرت حوالي 6
ساعات
داهم الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من 100 منزل
وعبث بمحتوياتها اضافه الى اقتحام عشرات
الاليات العسكريه برفقه الجرافات الى داخل
ازقه المخيم اثناء عمليه
الاعتقالات التي نفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي
وطالت حوالي 13 فلسطينيا جرت هناك
اشتباكات مسلحه داخل الازقه واضافه الى
مواجهات على مداخل مخيم عقبه جبر
العمليه كما قلت لك فاطمه انتهت عند
الخامسه فجرا السكان المخيم يقولون بان
هذه العمليه هي الاضخم منذ سنوات والتي
ينفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيمه عقبه
جبر وليس ولكن ليست المره الاولى التي
يحاصر فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم
ويقتحمه لاعتقال مطلوبين
فلسطينيين بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه فاطمه
كان هناك عمليات اجتياح واقتحامات لعدد من
المدن الفلسطينيه اسفرت عن اعتقال عدد من
الفلسطينيين في نفس التوقيت الذي كان فيه
اقتحام لمخيم عقبه جبر كانت هناك هجمات
للمستوطنين في شمال الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا
في قريه برقه الى الشمال من مدينه نابلس
حيث هاجم مستوطنوا مستوطنه حومش المخلاه
والتي اقر الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بجواز عوده
المستوطنين اليها الاسبوع الماضي
هاجموا منازل المستوطنين على اطراف بلده
برقه وقاموا باحراق مزرعه للاغنام وعشرات
الاشجار من الزيتون اثناء ذلك لهم
الفلسطينيون
بالحجاره وجرت مواجهات بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي والفلسطينيين اسفرت عن اصابه
اربعه فلسطينيين بالرصاص اضافه الى
العشرات بالاختناق جراء استنشاق الغاز
المسيل للدموع شكرا جزيلا لك من مخيم عقبه
جبر في اريحا مراسل العربيه خالد القاسم
الى واشنطن والتي اعلنت عن
حلفائها وعدد من حلفائها الغربيين وشركه
مايكروسوفت ان جهه فاعله سيبرانيه مدعومه
من بكين تسللت الى شبكات للبنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في الولايات المتحده محذرين من ان
هجمات مماثله قد تحدث في جميع انحاء
العالم وفي تحذير مشترك قالت سلطات الامن
السيبراني في الولايات المتحده ودول غربيه
اخرى قالت انها رصدت مجموعه من الانشطه
مرتبطه بمجموعه تدعى
في حين قالت مايكروسوفت في بيان منفصل ان
الهجوم يهدد باحداث اضطرابات في البناء
التحتيه الحيويه للاتصالات بين الولايات
المتحده والمنطقه الاسيويه في الازمات
المستقبليه الصين ردت واتهمت الخارجيه
الصينيه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
بالتضليل على خلفيته هجوم الكتروني
وعمليات تجسس استهدفت بنيه تحتيه حيويه
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره انه لا دليل
على هذه التقارير التي تستهدف التضليل
اساءه سمعه الصين الدوليه بحسب تعبيرها
لكن من هي مجموعه فولت تايمون مشاهدينا
والتي تقف وراء هذا الهجوم السيبراني
اوضحت شركه مايكروسوفت في بيان لها ان هذه
المجموعه تنشط منذ عام 2021 في استهداف
ولمؤسسات البنيه التحتيه والتي تشمل
مؤسسات تعمل في قطاع الاتصالات والصناعه
والمرافق العامه والنقل والبناء بالاضافه
الى البحريه والتعليم وحددت مسارات هذه
المجموعه بانها تعمل ضمن اربعه تكتيكات
الاول جمع البيانات بما في ذلك بيانات
الانظمه المحليه والشبكات المرتبطه بها
الثاني وضع هذه البيانات في ملفات ارشيفيه
متسلسله والثالث استخدامه هذه البيانات
المسروقه وافساح الطريق امامهم للوصول
اليها اما الرابع والاخير فدمجه انظمه ضمن
نطاق عمل الشبكات في المؤسسات والتي
تخترقها لتوجيه حركه مرور البيانات عبر
معداتها التي تستخدم انظمه مفتوحه المصدر
لتسهيل الولوج اليها وقت الحاجه حول ذلك
وللمزيد ينضم الينا من الكويت مستشار امن
المعلومات والتحول الرقمي رونالد ابي نجم
اهلا بك معنا السيده رولاند بدايه يعني
هذا الهجوم وهذا النوع من الهجمات
السيبرانيه هل هو سهل الكشف عنها والتوصل
الى من وراءها
اول شيء صباح الخير فاطمه
بطبيعه الحال ابدا مش سهل لانه هذا النوع
الاختراقات هو صراحه الاخطر من بعض
الاختراق اللي صار لوزاره الخزانه
الامريكانيه عام 2020 وهذا النوع من
الاختراقات بكون عم بيشتغل بنسميه نحن
عميل متخفي بيكون موجود بالسيستنت وبياخد
فتره طويله يتم اكتشافه يعني احنا هلا عم
نحكي هون انه مايكروسوفت قالت انه هذا
الموجود
2021 يعني من نص عام 2021 واخدت معهم على
الاقل سنه ونص اذا مش اكتر لاكتشفوا هذا
النوع من الاختراقات فهذا اكبر خطوره
موجوده انه بهاي الفتره قديش
صار في سرقه بيانات وغيرها هون المصيبه
الكبيره طيب يعني هم يتهمون الصين انها
داعمه لهذه المجموعه هل يمكن التحقق من
ذلك هل يمكن اظهار ادله حول ذلك
بهذا الموضوع دائما عم تشوف الولايات
المتحده روسيه بعمليات اختراق وبتتهم
السين وغيرها هلا للمشكل انه ما في ولا
مره راح يكون في عنا قاضي او دجاج يحكم
ويطلع قرار بس دائما اتهامات بيكون على
اذا بدك طرق عمل البعض المجموعات
المخترقين يلي بتصير المجموعات الروسيه في
لها طريقه عمل وعندها اهداف معينه
للمجموعات الصينيه
الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه بامكانهم
تقنيا التحقق من خلفهم من يدعمهم واظهار
ذلك بالادله ام لا
هلا هذا المشكل برجع بقول التقنيه عم
بيقدر يعملوا شيء بنسميه دجاجه
الجنائيه الالكترونيه تيقدر يعملوا من ورا
هذا الموضوع فهذا الموضوع اذا بدك بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده انه ثبتوا هذا الموضوع
واتهموا الصين بهالطريقه بس برجع بقول سين
نفت مين يلي بده يجي ياكد هذا الموضوع
صحيح ولا لا دايما عنا هذا الاشكاليه طيب
كيف يمكن التصدي لهذه الهجمات التي وصفتها
سيدرا بانها الاخطر
صراحه اول شيء هي الاخطر لانه اول شي عم
تستهدف قاعدات عسكريه امريكانيه عم تاخذ
وقت طويل تيتم اكتشافها والاخطر من هذا
كله انه هي عم تربط اذا بدك عم تستهدف كل
شيء له علاقه بالاتصالات بين امريكا واسيا
مثل ما حكينا هلا خطوره هذا الموضوع انه
اصعب بكثير لانه كلنا بنعرف ما في شيء
اسمه بالامن السيبرانيتي 100%
امنين خاصه انه هذا النوع الاختراقات بتم
عبر الشيء نحن بنسميه فيشن ايميل او
مالشيز يعني يا ايميلات فيها اذا بدك
روابط بتادي لعمليات اختراق يا عبر مواقع
الكترونيه بينزل منها هذا الفيروس اذا بدك
فكلماليك دائما بتصير من وراء خطا بشري
يعني
اذا بدك الكتيبه كل العسكريه الامريكانيه
يكبس على فيش ايميل واحد راح تؤدي لهذه
عمليه الاختراق فكلماكن الصعوبه انه يقدر
يسيطر عليها 100% طيب بعد حدوث كل ذلك كيف
يمكن تفادي هذه المشاكل يعني من 2021 لا
يعلمون ماذا تم اختراقه وما الذي تم سرقته
بالتالي كيف يمكن منع حدوث ذلك في
المستقبل اعلم انك ذكرت بانه صعب جدا يعني
ممكن بزر واحد وضغطه واحده ولكن هل من طرق
اخرى يمكن المحاوله والعمل عليها لمنعهم
من الولوج والدخول في اي شركات او اي
اتصالات مستقبليه
للاسف برجع بقول باكد اكيد من المستحيل
انه منع اي جهه بيقدروا واحد يعلي اللافل
تبعهوله بيقدر يطور انظمه الامل والحمايه
بيقدر يعمل دورات تدريبيه للموظفين
تيتفادوا هذا الموضوع بس المنع الكامل
مستحيل وخاصه هلا هذا الشيء اكتشفوه انا
باكد لك في غير اشياء اكثر واكثر من هذا
الشيء بعد هلا لم يتم اكتشافه بوزاره
الخزانه الامريكانيه عام 2020 كمان انهم
اكثر من ست شهور مخترقين كل شيء في اجهزه
امن وحمايه موجوده عندهم والخطوره الاكبر
يلي هيدا نحن عم نحكي عنه هلا وفي معطيات
بهذا الموضوع انه عم ينعمل شي نحن بنسميه
سبلايين اتاك يعني انه نحن بنروح الشركات
اوجيات الحكوميه الامريكانيه وغيرها
بيجيبوا شركات من اهم الشركات بالعالم مثل
ما صار قبل مع فاير اي
وصلوا اهم الشركات تيحمون المخترقين عم
يخترقوا هذه الشركات وعم بيقدر يفوتوا
عبرها فاذا نعم شو عم جيب اجهزه حمايه
وشركات واهم شركات العالم وعم بيتم
اختراقها كيف بعد بقدر اعمل بعض اكتر ربما
شكرا جزيلا لك من الكويت مستشار امن
المعلومات والتحول الرقمي رونالد ابينا
الجيم
بموازات الهجوم السبراني الذين فاتوا بكين
كشفت صور لقمر صناعيا امريكي عن قيام
الصين بارسال مسيره متطوره لقاعده عسكريه
في شرق الصين ما اثار المخاوف حول قيام
بكين بحشد قدراته العسكريه قبيله هجوم
محتمل على جزيره تايوان
طائره بدون طيار صينيه
تفوق سرعه الصوت
تستخدم لعمليه الرصد والتجسس
كشفت عنها الصين عام 2019
قادره على القيام بالتجسس الاستراتيجي
مداها يسمح لها بالوصول لتايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
ارسلتها بكين لقاعده الوان العسكريه
القاعده تقع في محافظه الوان شرقي البلاد
على مسافه قصيره
تم تعديل المدرج لكي يستقبل المسيرات
المتطوره في الاسابيع الاخيره قامت مسيرات
صينيه بالطيران حول الجزيره هدف العمليه
كان اثبات قدرات بكين على التجسس ورصد
الاهداف التايوانيه
لتوجيه ضربات صاروخيه
وتيره كسرعه البرق ربما تلك 45 عاما ورغما
انخفاض معدل التضخم السنوي بشكل حاد الى
ادنى مستوى له في 13 شهرا مسجلا ثمانيه
فاصله سبعه في المئه لكن الاسعار ما زالت
مرتفعه في خضم ازمه غلاء المعيشه اذ يناهز
التضخم السنوي لاسعار المواد الغذائيه
اعلى معدلاتها التاريخيه مع استقرارهم عند
19% ورغم ارتفاع الاسعار هذا الا ان
الشارع البريطاني متفائل بانخفاض التضخم
ويرجو ان يؤثر ذلك ايجابيا على اسعار
المواد الغذائيه
اعتقد ان الامور بدات في تحسن في بريطانيا
نامل ان تكون علامه على ان القادم يكمن في
انخفاض معدلات التضخم وسعر الفائده
على الناس الشعور بالتفاؤل التضخم كاي شيء
اخر في الحياه متفاوت بشكل مستمر وبالتالي
لا يمكن التنبؤ به واذا ما استطعت فستكون
عبقريا وستجني مالا من وراء ذلك
انها علامه جيده وخطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح
اليس كذلك لذا دعونا نامل ان يستمر هذا
الوضع فما زلنا في الشهر الاول
رغم ضعف التبادل التجاري بين البلدين خلال
العقود الماضيه تمر العلاقات السعوديه
العراقيه الاقتصاديه فتره ازدهار حيث
انشات صناديق سعوديه عراقيه للاستثمار في
العراق بالاضافه الى تطلع شركات سعوديه
كبرى الى الدخول في السوق العراقي وذلك
تزامنا مع فتح المنفذ الحدوديه السعودي
العراقي الذي رفع من التبادل التجاري بين
البلدين 25% نتابع التفاصيل في العرض
التالي مع عبد المحسن الحربي
حراك اقتصادي سعودي عراقي يتنامى بشكل
مضطرد سنويا
مدعوما برغبه سياسيه من قياده البلدين
رفعت حجم التبادل التجاري بين البلدين الى
20 مليار ريال خلال الفتره بين عامي 2016
و 2021
ومصحوبا بخطوات لتسهيل ارتفاع هذا الرقم
كالترخيص لافتتاح فرعي المصرف العراقي
للتجاره والمصرف الاهلي العراقي في
السعوديه لا شك ان وجود مصرف عراقي كجزء
من القطاع المصرفي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بيكون لها دور كبير وفعال في حل
معوقات الماليه بين البلدين وتواجد المصرف
نتج عنه توقيع اول اتفاقيه من نوعها مع
بنك التصدير الاستيراد السعودي لتمويل
التجار والشركات العراقيه في تعاملاتهم
التجاريه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وباسعار منافسه مقارنه بكلف التمويل
المعمول بها حاليا في ع راق الشقيق
السعوديه اعلنت عن تاسيس شركه للاستثمار
في العراق بالاضافه الى صندوق الاستثماري
سعودي عراقي براس مال ثلاثه مليارات ريال
للاستثمار في قطاعات مختلفه بالعراق ومن
المتوقع ان ترفع حجم الاستثمارات السعوديه
في العراق الى عشره مليارات ريال لازال
الحقيقه حجم التبادل التجاري ضعيف اذا ما
يعني ان شاء الله تعالى انا اعتقد انه
خلال فتره القادمه الخمس ست سنوات القادمه
سينمو بمعدلات متضاعفه ربما تتجاوز
الخمسين والسبعين في المئه سنويا وهذا
سيجعل العراق في مصاف العشر دول الاولى في
حجم التبادل التجاري مع المملكه نعم
الصادرات السعوديه التي انشات مركزا
للشركات السعوديه في بغداد قالت ان صادرات
المملكه غير النفطيه الى العراق من 2018
الى 2022
بلغت 14 مليار ريال داعيه الى تعزيز
الاستثمار السعودي في العراق في ظل مؤشرات
زياده الحركه التجاريه بين السعوديه
والعراق سعي سعودي عراقي لتاكيد تحسن
العلاقات بين البلدين من خلال بوابه
الاقتصاد عبر تدليل كافه الصعوبات
للاستثمار في البلدين عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه جده
اعلنت وكاله فيتش للتصنيف الائتماني انها
وضعت التصنيف الائتماني للولايات المتحده
تحت المراقبه وذلك تمهيدا لاحتمال خفضه في
حال تخلفت واشنطن عن سداد ديونها اذا لم
يتم رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي وقالت
الوكاله في بيان ان الولايات المتحده ما
زالت تتمتع حتى الان بالتصنيف الممتاز لكن
قرارها هذا يعكس التوترات السياسيه
المتزايده والتي تعيق حل المشكله عبر رفع
سقف الدين العام او تعليق العمل به في وقت
يقترب فيه الموعد النهائي لبلوغ الدين
العام الامريكي للسقف المحدد له قانونيا
تحولت قضيه رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي
الى مفاوضات علنيه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين حول اداره الميزانيه
والاقتصاد الامريكي لا لكنني تحدثت الى
البيت الابيض واخرين وساخبركم بالتطورات
هذا الصباح
يتهم الديمقراطيون الجمهوريين بسوء النيه
في التفاوض والتسبب بعدم رفع سقف الدين
وبازمه اقتصاديه وماليه عالميه بعض الكلام
على منبر مجلس النواب كان قاسيه
نجد انفسنا في هذا الموقع ليس لانه ليس
لدينا المال فنحن اغنى دوله في العالم بل
لان زملائنا الجمهوريين وضعونا في موقع
الرهان
وزير الخزانه جانتيلين تقول ان التمويل
ينفذ بعد ثمانيه ايام ومع ذلك لم يسوت
مجلس الشيوخ الذي يسيطر عليه الديمقراطيون
على اي مشروع قانون لتحاشي المشكله
ومع تقاصر مهله الطرفين في التوصل الى حل
حذرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جاني من ان
اسواق السندات تتعرض لضغوطات بسبب تاخر
المفاوضات في الوصول الى نتيجه
نرى بعض الضغط في السوق الخزانه واعتقد ان
الامر تذكير بضروره التوصل الى اتفاق في
الوقت المناسب
ولا يبدو ان الطرفين وصل الى اي تفاهمات
فرئيس مجلس النواب كرر في اروقه الكونجرس
كل ما قيل من قبل ولا ما الرئيس بايدن
والديمقراطيين وطالب بخفض المصروفات ووقف
الاستدامه سارسل المفاوضين الى البيت
الابيض في محاوله للتوصل الى اتفاق فنحن
لا زلنا على خلاف عميق في عدد من القضايا
يتصرف الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون وكان
لديهم الوقت الكافي للتوصل الى اتفاق قبل
ان تضطر وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه الى وقف
بعض المدفوعات
هي الغنمه العربيه من امام وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه
اندلع حريق ضخم في مبنى مكون من سبعه
طوابق في مدينه سيدني الاستراليه وقالت
اداره الاطفاء في ولايه نيو سافويلز ان
المبنى في طور الانهيار فيما بدا الحريق
يمتد الى مباني قريبه بما فيها مباني
سكنيه
من الحرائق الى الاعاصير فتحول اعصار
ماوار الى عاصفه قويه من الفئه الرابعه مع
وصوله الى جزيره غوام النائيه في المحيط
الهادئ وضربت الرياح الشديده والامطار
الغزيره جزيره غوام والتره السكان الى
البقاء ساعات طويله من دون كهرباء ومرافق
وتسببت العاصفه في تدمير اسطح المنازل
والسيارات واقتلاع الاشجار
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات